بعد ان اطلق سراحه بكفاله ايدت محكمه
الاستئناف بالرباط الحكم على المحامي
والوزير السابق لحقوق الانسان محمد زيان
بالسجن ثلاثه اعوام النيابه العامه وجهت
اليه 11 تهمه بينها اهانه رجال القضاء
وهيئات المنظمه وبث وقائعها والدعاءات
كاذبه والخيانه الزوجيه بالاضافه الى
التحرش الجنسي تعود حيثيه القضيه الى
اواخر العام 2020 عندما لدد زيان بتعرضه
لحمله تشهير على اثر بث موقع اخباري مقطع
فيديو له داخل غرفه مع احدى موكلاتهم
زيان المخابرات الداخليه بالوقوف خلف
فبركه هذا الفيديو ورده على هذا الاتهام
اعلنت وزاره الداخليه
بمهاجمه مؤسسه الدوله عبر الترويج
الاتهامات والدعاءات باطله لكن نجل الوزير
السابق خبر ان والده كان مستهدفا منذ دفعه
عن نشطاء الحراك الريف في مدينه الحسيمه
ونواحيها شمال المملكه بين عام 2016
و2017 بالاضافه الى دفاعه عن الصحفي توفيق
بوعشرين المسجونين منذ 2018 هذا وبدوري
هذانه الهيئه الوطنيه لمسانده معتقلي
الراي سجن زيان مشيره انه يعد انتهاكا
جسيما لقانون المسطره الجنائيه وللدستور